now last year exports of Rose a wine
from France increased 29% as Americans
fell in love with the dry pink colored
wine but much to the disappointment of
some consumers there was a rose a
shortage last summer
Bloomberg's own Olivia Sterns found some
social media stars looking to make money
on a solution
first of all panic do you know the fat
Jew I've seen him on Bloomberg he is a
sort of Instagram King he's a social
media sensation he is teaming up with a
guy called David Oliver Cohen who is
sort of half the brains behind another
social media sensation called white girl
problems ever heard of it babe why is
that one anyway it's a really
interesting story because here are these
two guys who have this huge viral
following who are doing all these crazy
marketing stunts and now here they are
getting into the real world with a real
commercial product it is called white
girl Rose Day so I wasn't sure if it was
a joke or not and that's kind of where I
started the conversation have a listen
last summer in the Hamptons there was a
rose a shortage people were running for
the streets screaming there was not
enough Rose a people were hoarding it in
their arm it's running through the
streets and we sat back and watched you
know as it all unfolded and we said
never again so it's more of a
humanitarian endeavor
yeah we're givers we're givers we want
to make sure that you know there would
never be not enough Rose a for everybody
so we figured why don't we just make it
yeah we felt like we can do this better
than anyone else
exactly never done it before right and
it's always one of those things where if
you've never done it you could just
learn all the things you need to do to
get it done yes we did a hundred percent
all right you guys are serious about
this how many bottles have you actually
made we are in the process of bottling
as we speak
our first order is 30,000 bottles Wow we
want to be national by next summer one
year from now a million bottle salt and
how are you positioning it is it up
market how much does it cost
suggested retail $14.99 at the store so
it's reasonable right sure like you're
kind of balling but you're not really
balling you know what I mean it's not
$8.99 you know what I'm saying this
isn't Trader Joe's talk to me about the
name white girl Rose a some might find
that a little offensive well part of
our brand white girl problems is it's
really more platform from which we can
all stand and air our grievances so you
don't have to be a white person or a
girl a white girl problem because
problems are relative so if you have an
issue it could be a white go problem
it's really more white people less white
people sort of making fun of themselves
and everyone can make fun of themselves
but since you say this is serious
no you're actually trying to market this
also to men because there's this growing
bros a movement so truly by anything it
men with a product called white girl
Rosa that's that's right because because
like you know like white girl it's like
a it's a state of mind you're not I mean
you have to like you get you know what
I'm saying you did a man sexual exactly
it's it's it's just for everybody and
like you know all guys I think have a
little a little bit of white girl in
them and I think they should embrace it
and we embrace the bros a movement so
more and more men apparently are
drinking rose' and they're actually
trying to tap into this legitimate
market trend
are you drinking rosy I mean I know you
know a lot about wine I want to ask you
first did you try it it's under my desk
we can open it all right and who makes
it because they don't own the vineyards
that make that they put the label on the
bottle I would imagine yes is white girl
Rose a bottling so they're doing it in
conjunction with a wine producer right
now but it's selling on fresh is it in
is the wine producer based in France I
mean in the u.s. it's based in the US
and wool for a state that just wanted to
make sure you know Rosa just wanted to
check